[Musique]
bienvenue pour ce nouveau numéro d'
envies de lecture bonjour nathalie wolf
que vous connaissez particulièrement
bien c'est le livre pour jeunesse
puisque tous hommes avec sylvie vassallo
qui la directrice du salon du livre
de montreuil bonjour sylvie vassallo
alors vous êtes vous êtes en place à
l'eau qui se tient jusqu'au 6 décembre
c'est 37e salon du livre de la de la
jeunesse de montreuil
c'est un événement qui est devenue
aujourd'hui un incontournable au fil des
ans et 1 300 exposants plus de plus près
de son auteur c'est le rendez vous
annuel du livre de de la littérature de
jeunesse
un mou peut-être sur le succès justement
grandissant et de ce salon est de la
littérature pour jeunes s est ce que est
ce que cette littérature et est
considérée aujourd'hui comme une vraie
littérature
en tout cas les considérer comme une
vraie littérature par son public par les
enfants parler par les parents parce
qu'ils les accompagnent on voit ici se
presser dans les allées du salon des
enseignants par exemple qui ont
accompagné leur classe qui considère que
c'est vraiment très important de
découvrir cette découvrir ses livres
cette littérature je crois que les
écrivains les illustrateurs les
illustratrices sont de plus en plus
reconnue si l'écart à turin assez
spéciale puisqu'elle manie le texte et
l'image avec beaucoup de dextérité
après de là à dire qu'elle est vraiment
reconnue au même titre que de la
littérature je voulais qu'il ira tueur
général je suis pas encore complètement
convaincu mais c'est encore un combat
qu'a mené mais qui progresse
on voit que les enfants les adolescents
qui sont de plus en plus attirés par la
vidéo est-ce que c'est difficile de leur
faire admettre et devait de convaincre
les parents que le livre dans cette
année non plus
je crois que c'est assez complémentaires
comme comme expérience culturelle pour
les enfants et pour les jeunes c'est
vrai que la question qui est posée c'est
leur permettre à moment donné d'être en
contact avec le livre de façon agréable
plaisante intéressante parce que le
livre ses passagers présents c'est
quelque chose qui nous fait voyager à
l'intérieur du fourgon direction les
autres le monde à travers du temps les
époques si on n'a pas été sur n'a pas
fait cette expérience n'est pas
forcément
on n'a pas forcément envie de
recommencer non pour des enfants
certains enfants il faut des événements
comme celui-ci où il est l'auteur voile
est perçu république pour entrer en
connexion objets mais une fois que c'est
fait il ya une vraie la complémentarité
entre le livre et les écrans et
d'ailleurs ils vous êtes d'habitation
mussig qui permettent de facile de l'un
à l'autre que oui c'est faut le faire
mais c'est passé difficile à faire le
cabinet va de quel âge ac et l'aj
auxerre quand on dit des terrains pour
le deuil c'est vrai quoi
en fait ça va des bébés ce qui a
vraiment de plus en plus de rage du
littérature pour les bébés jusqu'aux
adolescents et d'adolescence aujourd'hui
ça va loin c'est à dire que la
littérature des adolescents c'est une
littérature que les adultes peuvent
également lire dans laquelle ils peuvent
se retrouver absolument et puis dans un
salon comme celui ci il ya des adultes
aussi connaisseur de littérature de
jeunesse qui viennent pour la dimension
artistique de cette littérature et
notamment de la littérature d'image de
roman graphique de bande dessinée aussi
de grands albums illustrés
et alors le titre de ce de ceux de ce
salon c'est nous 1
nous c'est d'ailleurs c'est un titre un
peu paradoxal parce qu'après tout
l'écriture c'est un exercice solitaire
pourquoi avoir choisi nous
oui alors l'écriture est un exercice
solitaire est souvent la lecture aussi
est un exercice solidaire c'est c'est
vrai que c'est ça peut paraître un peu à
peu curieux en fait on a voulu après
c'est moi c'est moi compliqué dans
lesquelles nous sommes encore plongé de
crise sanitaire comme on est assez
isolés les uns des autres mais compris
le contact physique et est problématique
on a voulu redonner une image pour
donner une cohérence à la question du
nuit à ce qui nous fait avancer
finalement à l'alcool fait qu' on n'est
rien seul on est en relation c'est la
relation avec les autres qui absolument
importante donc la littérature c'est une
façon de raconter des histoires d'un
collectif l'histoire du goût oblige
histoire l'histoire des banques par
exemple il verse helmand qui est une
façon aussi entre et éducation de la
question du loup et de l'abonnement
c'est pas forcément facile le groupe ne
peut pas être parfois excluant il ya
beaucoup d'histoire là qui traite de ces
questions mais aussi du nous qui permet
d'avancer d'une jeune il faut faire
attention parce qu'il ya des fragilités
dans les relations d'avant les uns avec
les autres du nom qui permet aussi de
grandir quand on est enfant et pour
chercher sa place naples un moment il ya
plein de phases de sa vie d'enfant
d'admission où on se demande ce qu'on
fait dans le dans l'ensemble et dans
l'eau dans la fête voilà tout ça c'est
ce qu'on a voulu aborder avec cette
question
et lors quelles sont les grandes
tendances de la littérature jeunesse on
se demandait si finalement ce qu'il n'y
avait pas des modes aussi moi j'ai
l'impression en allant dans les
librairies qui lie à un nombre
exponentiel de petits essais sur les
hommes et les femmes célèbres le genre
les discriminations l'environnement
d'ailleurs vous avez écrit une tribune
il ya quelques années dans le monde vous
dit les livres de jeunesse ne sont pas
des manuels de morale est ce que ces
livres qui sont le reflet bien sûr de
notre société mais est ce que la
littérature
n'a pas d'abord pour vocation de faire
rêver et des veillées à l'étonnement
d'éveiller nos enfants au merveilleux
quoi qu'il a appelés il appelait 2 c'est
à dire que on a le caractère de jeu
laisse comprennent budget c'est que ces
gens va le brosse vraiment une grande
diversité de chambre est due pour
adultes ces thématiques aussi donc c'est
vrai on voit à quel point à des prisons
le reflet de questions sociales
importantes ou de deux problématiques
sociales la question des genres la
question de questions de l'écologie par
exemple soit extrêmement prénom
prégnante dans la littérature jeunesse
mais ça n'empêche pas forcément qu'elle
se retrouve avec les questions
d'imaginaire et on voit par exemple dans
toute la littérature fantastique
extrêmement prisées par les adolescents
il ya également des thématiques sociales
qui sont abordés je crois que la
question qui est posée c'est plutôt
comment ça reste une littérature de
fiction une littérature qui emmène vers
des espaces imaginaires et qui donne pas
des leçons qui me passent à des messages
d'ailleurs partout et il faut lire échec
depuis trois ans yadav décerné le de
récompenses qui est celle de la grande
ourse usine base d il ya eu marie
desplechin et cette année c'est lucie
félix vous pouvez nous dire eu de mots
de lucie félix
oui alors lui si phoenix c'est une assez
jeune finalement au tri sera triste elle
n'a pas pu attendent tant qu'ouvrage que
ça je crois qu'elle en a publié six ou
sept elle écrit pour les tout petits
pour les bébés et elle a un talon assez
extraordinaire pour offrir des livres
qui sont interactifs qui permettent qui
engage le parent dans la lecture avec
son enfant par toute une gestuelle de
lecture chaque livre est différent et
chaque fois elle joue sur des gestes de
relations entre le parent et l'enfant
dans la lecture c'est depuis s'il a
expliqué quand on voit pas ses livres
mais vous en voyez à l'écran est par
exemple coucou c'est un livre qui joue
sur la lumière sur le fait que le liban
entre le parent et l'enfant et qu'on se
regarde à travers mais
aussi les ventes et pitt en compétition
pour la pour la pépite d'or je crois que
les livres sont sont d'abord sélectionné
par des jeunes enfants de 8 à 18 ans
puis a pris un jury professionnel qui
désigne la pépite d'or et vous nous avez
aussi préparé une sélection et voilà
noël arrivant je note patrice et mois la
voilà vous pouvez nous parler un peu de
alors mon cher et demi on va commencer
par mon cher ennemi qui ne correspondent
en centrant lapin et un renard de
thierry dedieu des gilles boum c'est la
grosse dose entre gaspard goupil et
jeannot lapin si je crois en fait c'est
un livre un peu après qui sort des
sentiers battus c'est effectivement une
correspondance entre 2,2 et me moque
tout pour se détester puisque c'est le
et la peau et la proie de l'autre et il
y aurait cependant ce qui s'engagent le
premier n'a pas lui disent tu te
souviens tu de certains coûts s'est
passé quelque chose entre nous et il se
rend compte au fur et à mesure de son se
rend compte le lecteur se rend compte au
fur et à mesure de la correspondance
qu'ils ont vécu un événement dramatique
ensemble qui les a rassemblés au delà de
ce qu'il se passe
deuxième livre esprit es tu là de
dominique et raretés florence et anne
florence pardon le masson édition des
grandes personnes
alors ça c'est un petit peu probable et
pop up ce sont des vivres en volume
c'est un canton dont les pages il ya des
images qui ressorte en volume
et c'est un livre précieux qui racontent
ce que 20 qui met en avant un personnage
un personnage qui est un esprit est
derrière qui parle d'un petit texte très
court de ce personnage ce que ce
personnage peut permettre de faire pour
un enfant qui est élu en colère et c'est
donc qu'ils parlent les émotions des
enfants ce livre ça a été la pépite de
des enfants pour le livre illustré et
ils disent que c'est extrêmement
poétique et ce alors ça leur a beaucoup
parlé de leurs propres émotions vous
avez été touchés on arrive à parler de
leurs émotions
autrefois alors qu'il s'adresse à un
public un peu plus âgé je crois que je
pense c'est l'enfer de martin de d'un os
d'édition inuits et c'est qui est un
robot sur sur le bagne et des îles du
salut
oui c'est ça alors là c'est que c'est
carrément effectivement un ouvrage qui
s'adresse à tous vie à des enfants va
des adolescents plus tôt aston vosges
extrêmement bien écrit une écriture
assez exceptionnel qui va nous plonger
dans un enfant de notre histoire à
travers une relation une relation qui se
fait presque juste par le regard entre
un bagnard est une petite fille qui est
la petite fille qui la fit préfet du
lieu et qui elle va regarder cet enfant
il ya une chose qui se fait entre les
deux dont tu rentres l'emprisonner un
pas l'emprisonnement puisqu'elle n'y
absolument rien mais un espèce de
souffle de liberté dans cet ouvrage qui
a c'est assez étonnant un texte court et
très très fort d'accord oui qui renvoie
victor hugo et qui avait assisté à des
add des condamnations à mort et qui se
mettra à lutter contre la peine de mort
ensuite coulisses ça sert nos intérêts
c'est parce que vous parliez tout à
l'heure de problèmes sociétaux la saison
on est dans l'oeil elle presque avec
polir de de fabrice melquiot et isabelle
palau des éditions la joie de lire tout
à fait c'est un ouvrage assez a là
encore assez étonnant qui a été choisie
comme pépite par par les adolescents il
est ou non parce que il raconte une
histoire qui est relativement peu connue
celle des enfants qui naissent intersec
c'est à dire vraiment entre les entre
les deux sexes de ce qui leur arrive et
des débats qui peut y avoir au sein du
milieu médical et de la femme mais
surtout ce qui est étonnant dans cet
ouvrage c'est le fait que ce soit écrit
et scénarisé par un auteur de théâtre et
ensuite illustré et du coup il ya une
sorte de lecture théâtrale en forme de
vente décidée moi je crois je n'avais
jamais vu ça
on a eu vraiment con plaisir à voir que
ça tous les soins elle avait choisi leur
pépite
les derniers livres lé dernier livre
développe le naufrage est de
sélectionner les reflets d'art y est de
marine caddie édition les éditions les
grumes 1
alors ça c'est à lui qui est dans notre
exposition de notre usine à nous donc à
l'intérieur ou des au démarrage du salon
ça raconte l'histoire d'un lion qui
vient de mourir et qui cherche à
s'incarner dans un d'antan quelqu'un
d'autre pour continuer à vivre qui fait
un peu du tour autour de lui et
finalement il choisit cette petite fille
harriet c'est un sacré mauvais caractère
qui se reconnaît en elle il décide de
sauter dans son projet au moment où elle
passe se reflète dans une flaque d'eau
et du coup elle prend son caractère et
cette petite fille elle va tout de suite
que ça va être c'est quand même assez
super parce que la came détermination
une force un peu incomparable mais 50
quelques inconvénients parce qu'il
comptait dessus mère du gérant classe
évidemment la vie très sépare tout à
fait d'accord avec ça et voilà donc il
s'ensuit un peu des péripéties comme ça
c'est assez drôle je pense que ça parle
pas mal aux enfants de jeu merci à vis
du mot sylvie vassallo d'avoir devoir
consacrer quelques quelques instants en
plein en plein salon de montreuil bravo
pour ce salon qui est vraiment devenu un
instrument exceptionnel la pole pour la
littérature pour jeunesse et merci aussi
pour être pour les conseils j'espère que
les téléspectateurs ont pris des notes
pour se précipiter pour noël prôné pour
les cadeaux merci infiniment et
bravo merci beaucoup au revoir envois
faits trees are not only
[Musique]